[Music]
the US has woken up to a big risk when
it comes to energy 15 years ago China
could produce six times as many solar
panels as the US look at what's happened
since then it can now make 70 times as
many that massive production capacity
means China alone is able to install
more than half of the world's new solar
panels this year what's more it means
that the relatively little solar
capacity installed in the US is made
abroad often with components from China
B dominance in this space is a big deal
because solar energy will be the
dominant source of renewable energy by
the end of the decade and the world is
dependent on China for the technology
it's a vulnerability the US wants to fix
I've long said when I think climate not
a joke I think jobs the problem is that
while America was investing uh
sporadically in solar manufacturing
China was going all in they did
everything solar manufacturing is a
horrible business and nearly everyone
who's gone into it has failed the US is
making a multi-billion bet to get back
into that horrible business as a
transition to renewable energy gathers
Pace it's going to be a big
ask the impact of climate change is
already very real the summer of 2023 was
the hottest on record exceeding the
blistering temperatures of just a year
earlier it's the backdrop for the United
Nations annual climate talks cop 28
wants to see a tripling of Renewables by
the end of the decade solar is likely to
be the biggest part of that with three
times as much capacity worldwide as
onshore and offshore Wind by 2030 unlike
uh other types of renewable and
emission-free power solar can be
deployed very quickly it can be scaled
up rapidly and it can reduce emissions
in a very short time scale which is what
we need before we get into how the US
lost so much ground and President
Biden's efforts to regain some of it we
need to understand what a solar panel
consists of most of the weight is
actually just aluminum and glass but the
key material at the heart of it is
silicon because photovoltaic panels are
essentially semiconductors similar to
the chips that run your smartphone they
require a particular kind of silicon
with exceptionally High Purity hly
silicon is the raw material to make
solar modules you get it from Sand but
you need to refine it using a lot of
energy and a lot of complicated chemical
and physical processes so it's very
energy intensive to make and it's very
capex intensive to build the factories
to make it while the US used to have its
own polysilicon manufacturing China now
supplies 89% of the world's solar grade
polysilicon that wasn't always the case
Japan Germany and the us all used to be
major solar panel manufacturers 20 years
ago not only did China make very few
solar panels it had to import most of
the polysilicon needed to make them then
Beijing seemed to recognize something
China was able to identify solar as an
area where it could get in at the ground
floor it was an opportunity to really
take over this industry to dominate this
industry from 2004 Chinese companies
responded to International Demand by
setting up bigger factories for solar
than ever before with support from
government but also just competing to
supply a market Chinese companies
continued to innovate in terms of
pushing down costs and building up
unprecedented scale in manufacturing
those lower costs rapidly undercut the
existing players particularly after 2008
when Global capacity started to outstrip
demand that sent prices plummeting the
first big players in solar are mostly
gone now because solar is a viciously
competitive business take for example
the German company solar World in 2008
it was expanding in the US Go Solar with
solar World America's largest solar
panel manufacturer but frankly it just
couldn't compete it's one of the the
many solar manufacturing companies that
just couldn't make it in the US China's
massive bet was starting to pay off it
pulled out all the stops both on the
supply side and on the demand side they
offered cheap financing and cheap land
to solar manufacturing facilities and
they used incentives and subsidies to
encourage demand that's the other side
of this coin Beijing was also ensuring
that people in China would buy the solar
gear and critically it didn't need to
import oil or other fossil fuels for
this power in theory at least given
solar panels are made with coal power
all that needed was Sun sand and a ton
of
money that was also good for the world
it made solar panels way cheaper way
more quickly than anyone had anticipated
China is the reason why solar is not a
cottage industry anymore we're expecting
solar new build this year to be about
392 gaw which is a lot it's the
equivalent in generation terms of about
one nuclear reactor every 10 days more
than half of those solar panels will be
installed in China it's one hell of a
boom and US manufacturers are missing
out on it solar has just really exploded
around the world and the Us and other
countries frankly kind of discounted how
quickly it would become part of the
energy mix even so there are plenty who
say that the US doesn't need to make its
own panels China has made it cheap and
selling cheap keep things is generally a
terrible business there's an argument
that the US should just let China take
on that burden as it does with all sorts
of other electronics manufacturing
Reliance on any foreign supplier is
challenging geopolitical concerns can
get in the way and in the Solar Supply
Chain that's not just the solar panels
but also the inputs along the way to
making them it's the polysilicon it's
the Wafers if any company or country is
the sole supplier really of of some of
those inputs they can squeeze on prices
and they can also squeeze on Supply at
any given time China has a track record
here back in 2010 a territorial dispute
with Japan Sal Beijing restricts supply
of rare earth metals that are used in
laptop hard drives and car batteries if
the US's goal is to reduce that kind of
risk here's what it needs to do Boost
demand make Imports harder add support
for domestic manufacturing and make it
easier to build the projects the core of
these efforts is 2022 is inflation
uction act the inflation reduction Act
is very very generous every wafer every
cell every module that is made in the US
Factory gets a tax credit there's also
tons of support in the inflation
reduction act on the demand side of the
equation so there's direct money $7
billion of it designed to go to Rooftop
and Community solar projects expect
solar to rise on the agenda after cop 28
in Dubai China got a head start on this
Tech but that doesn't mean the US has
completely missed out I think the best
case for the US is that it continues to
support a domestic manufacturing
industry and have some control of its
Supply chains even if it pays a little
bit more than most countries do for
solar the US needs to get all in and it
needs to do everything right and it
needs to do it for a long time it has to
have staying power the lesson from the
last decade is that the US has to be
committed and it has to come to this as
committed as
[Music]
China